[Music]
you've seen it growing on your fruit
eating your leftovers and maybe even
hiding in your basement
this is mold it smells bad it's creepy
looking and even if you don't know much
about it you probably know enough to
keep it as far away from your mouth as
possible but what would happen if you
ate some without realizing it what would
it do to your body and is there any
situation where it could actually taste
good this is what if and here's what
would happen if you ate mold there are
up to three hundred thousand different
types of mold and they could affect you
in very different ways some could ruin
your day by causing nausea or diarrhea
some could be used to make expensive
cheeses and others could nearly kill you
so how do you know which kind of mold
you're dealing with and is it ever okay
to just eat around the mold on your food
I'm asking for a friend
mold is the microscopic fungi you can
find living on plants animals and even
in buildings molds form branches that
are like thin threads called hyphy these
can burrow into food something you might
miss since they can be difficult to see
if you do notice mold growing on your
food your first question will probably
be mm should I throw this away so we've
put together a little guide to help you
figure it out if you find mold on soft
foods like yogurts jams peaches or
tomatoes you should throw them out right
away but if you find mold on harder
foods like cheese carrots or hard salami
it's okay to cut the mold out and eat
the rest of your food harder denser
foods are more difficult for mold to
penetrate meaning it can't spread
inwards as quickly as it can in softer
foods but let's imagine that you didn't
have this handy guide and you ate some
moldy food what would happen to you well
the biggest problem wouldn't be the mold
itself it's the other things that come
along with the mold that could really
hurt you first off there's the invisible
bacteria that can accompany the mold if
you eat that bacteria you would
experience stomach pain vomiting and
several urgent trips to the washroom but
that would be nothing compared to the
damage that would come from eating
something called mycotoxins mycotoxins
are poisonous substances that are
produced by certain strains of mold they
can be found in a variety of foods and
can survive almost all kinds of food
processing there are many types of micro
toxins about 500 to be specific perhaps
the most dangerous variety is known as
aflatoxin aflatoxin grows on corn and
peanuts too much aflatoxin can cause
liver damage cancer DNA damage and
immune system deficiency but not all
mold is harmful in fact some people eat
mold on purpose take blue cheese for
example it's produced using the
non-toxic blue mold
Penicillium Rucka forte and Penicillium
glocken these molds have antibacterial
properties that enable them to suppress
pathogens they also break down proteins
which is why blue cheese is so creamy
and has a sharp flavor just like most
things on our planet there's more to
mold than meets the eye
sure it can make you sick but it's also
the key to one of the most powerful
antibiotics of all time penicillin
maybe there's another world-changing
innovation just waiting to be discovered
somewhere in that fuzzy blue mess but
that's a topic for another what-if